these days the world moves incredibly
fast work vacation school sports it
seems like we never have enough hours in
the day that's why shield is working to
guarantee that your family is kept safe
using the most advanced technology
available and the dedication of men and
women from across the globe we're
keeping a watchful eye to ensure that
your family stays protected but we also
know that sometimes events take place
outside of our control as the world
leader in safety and security our
mission is to ensure that conflicts like
sokovia and the Ultron incident don't
happen again that's why we're working
with the world's governments to make
sure that superheroes continue to help
keep us safe while also being held
accountable for what they do
registration it just makes sense